competitive play for blizzards popular
first-person shooter overwatch has made
its way to Xbox one and it sounds like
it came a little bit early Blizzard
released an update from Microsoft's
console earlier today even though it
wasn't expected to arrive until next
week this update hasn't made its way to
ps4 yet but we'll be sure to let you
know once it does overwatch is
competitive play mode is available after
you reach level 25 once you do that it
will show up under the play button in
the main menu if you're unsure how
competitive play works head on over to
gamespot com for a detailed breakdown on
the mode this update also adds a number
of gameplay tweaks including an option
to adjust aim assist strength don't
worry though because the default aim
assist is already at full strength this
update also removes the avoid player
option in McCree is now available as an
AI hero in player verse AI and custom
matches speaking of McCree he got nerfed
his bullet damage has been decreased
additionally Widowmaker also took a
slight hit her head shots are still
deadly but body shots aren't quite as
powerful for a full list of changes and
more on overwatch check out our article
on gamespot com